[Music]
avery bradley with the deflection
against
what an incredible block
that you're gonna ever see
yeah baines the initial defender and he
blocks it with two hands and almost
grabbed it off the glass the unreal play
by john moran i mean unreal is right
this guy just look where he is when he
catches it at the top of the square the
box on the back look at his hands
up there he almost hit his head on the
back don't hold back i just don't like
why we seem to love to get our oh what a
block from azeali
great
rotation by festus azeeli fournier to
inbound they run staggers
harris underneath rejected by town and
we're going to overtime here in orlando
really quick
i mean it's not even hardly out of his
hands and he's blocking the shot
[Applause]
[Music]
through the middle meyer's right block
shotgun hits it
he gets
it and the bucks win here's the block
what a block four
two
one
[Applause]
jeff green started running
from about the three-point line extended
on the offensive end
nick young started after the steal was
that half court knives hop step inside
blows it up misses rebound taken by
iguodala
bring a dollar to curry back to iguodala
up for the layup oh blocked by james
lebron james with the rejection
wow
great pass by curry running hard by
iguodala
and superhuman defensive recovery
by lebron james
[Applause]
deftly moves and tries to find the big
man inside they've been having a hard
time finding his rhythm ahead it goes
for curry oh what a play
simmons what hustle
talked about the points offensively
but this is his calling card right here
i don't know where
brother james is standing up
in northeast ohio and giving this young
man a standing ovation
i mean this is just an outstanding play
defensively
[Applause]
and booker will get the freebie now
durant saved
he thinks
he has a free one that's why he comes to
a jump stop and that enabled kevin
durant to have time to block the shot
curry answers with a three
walker comes free walker in the corner
blocked by rose
and the knicks win
nick's with a thriller here at the
garden they're six straight at home
you want to continue to look for that
back door cut for haywood
[Music]
mingles nice look go bear
wide head
isaiah whitehead
comes go bear but here's the little
delay and it's just enough to allow
since you have numbers turn around and
find the open man
leonard raises up
nothing with the bottom
ridiculous
[Applause]
spurs by a deuce or just come in come up
and shoot it harden blackberry
blocked by ambush spurring basketball i
don't want to play
oh what defense
unbelievable
nils and gordon
and picked up and that was a good call
because
the position helps anderson here's
hardened ginobili's adam he's got oh
[Applause]
gets it up to right
down to right good ball movement but
again a block by the sun's josh jackson
blocked it and stared marquise chris
with the dunk on the other end a little
stare down from jackson after that block
on one end and chris with the flush on
the other
the young sons
showing off the athleticism i was gonna
say
i can get you to carson city but that
might be it
zagaraj
[Applause]
coming at you
[Applause]
watch the celebration been very active
from the gun he also has three rebounds
and three assists and he's made three of
his four shots oh yes the great wall of
white side just rejected a jam blocked
it with two hands on that play but
there's no foul on this play watch it
again
blocked it with two hands
referees have a different kind of rule
[Music]
driving lebron james
what does a king always do to a prince
he puts him in his place
with a big time
quarter but lebron james
that is called
on the drive collins met at the rim by
chris whoa with a nasty rejection
some people will say that mutombo built
i know
marquise
he's got some bricks in here too
they're well timed for the absolute last
shot they're either going to win it or
go home with five with four the lakers
lead by one trey young's gonna do it
here he goes blocked by chander
lakers win it tyson chandler
welcome home
the lakers on the verge of losing this
one but tyson just enough of the shot
and you can see the red going around the
backboard meaning time is out boy he hit
it right at the apex too
that's a perfect block
by the veteran tyson chandler what a
finish
lakers get out of here for the win
16 last night 11 in the third quarter
williams down the lane there by oh
my goodness
way to get him
[Applause]
kidding me here
he hammers it
he hammers it
coach mcmillan had a little bit of my
view of watching it on tv i needed i
need to feel it real but it is a big
time block and i don't believe williams
will be going in there
clock at seven working against butler
got downhill couldn't punch it bam says
get it out of here
[Applause]
sky high
with the block and rejection at a bio
one
[Applause]
wow
a meeting at the summit doris that is a
ridiculous defensive play
jason tatum is clearly by everybody else
high above the rim pace the pace though
in the second half has been to the
liking of the los angeles clippers wow
zubats got blocked on the dunk giannis
shaking his head saying not
here so it looks like he's loose
and you see giannis come over and say no
sir
twice on the pipes here
uh uh
who's who's when you see a guy going
with that kind of force
who how many guys in the league willing
to meet him like that
[Music]
oh he's right there catch us
[Music]
oh
westbrook got there because it looked
like it was going to be a clean look for
levert who played well
home court
in that play-in situation
[Music]
they moved to ninth indiana drops to 10
on a night that russell westbrook makes
history
tying oscar robertson
and westbrook gets his second block of
the night
bradley with the deflection against
what an incredible block
that you're going to ever see
yeah baines the initial defender and he
blocks it with two hands and almost
grabbed it off the glass